[Music]
let's go to brandon in st louis what's
up brandon
what's up dr d how are you doing man
hey i'm doing good how are you good good
good what's up brother
hey i just had a quick question for you
hey hold on how old are you
i am 22 about to turn 23. all right man
it's like 10 to 15 years and counting
and it's gonna be colonoscopy time just
go ahead and put that on your calendar
man
all right so right what's up dude
hey um my wife and i we've been married
for
a little over three months now and i'm
just wondering if you have any advice
for keeping a healthy and sustainable
marriage
and the reason i'm asking is i just feel
like we're fighting a lot especially for
only being married for three months and
i'm wanting to you know i'm wanting
things to change and just wanting to
know
if you have any advice for
being a better husband and um keeping a
better relationship with my wife what
are y'all fighting about man
uh man we uh the primary things that we
fight about are
like
the way we both handle physical touch my
wife is not a physical touch person and
i am
and so
i feel like she's definitely like
changed um she tries to
we both try to meet in the middle but
sometimes i just kind of get upset
because
it's still different and then uh
hold on hold on
let's dig into that real quick and then
we'll go to the next one um yeah
you phrased that as you spoke about that
as
differences in physical touch needs okay
very common in marriages but the way you
ended up
you landed there was you feel deceived
she changed on you she used to be one
way you thought you were getting one
thing and now you've got something else
tell me more about that
yeah so uh we
when we were dating um it i like to hold
hands and you know like hug kind of in
public and i'm not i try not to be
cringy or anything obviously good don't
be gropey gary the groper
not at all all right and uh she's very
hesitant to do that and i went closer to
the time we were getting married i asked
her if that was going to change when
you're married because you know we were
going to make a lifetime commitment to
each other and she
was telling me that that it was going to
be different
because
we were going to be married and and it's
changed a little bit but i just i don't
think that it's changed as much as i
thought so i don't think that she's that
she deceived me by any chance by any by
any means but it kind of is a little
different than what i was thinking and
okay so you're trying to work through
that you you just nailed it you have a
picture of what lifetime commitment
looks like
yeah and it's that we
are high touch
high intimacy
sex all the time we hold hands in public
she
nuzzles the back of my neck you have all
these things that
this is what a lifetime commitment
romance looks like
fair right
yeah she has a different picture of what
lifetime commitment romance looks like
it might be you always have food on the
table and you always the trash just
magically disappears from inside the
house and the bed magically gets made
right so her picture of lifetime
commitment could look very different and
that is the dance of being married right
is
is coming up with a new picture okay so
you're you're on to the next thing what
was the next thing
yeah uh i would say that
the biggest thing uh is probably
so there's like little things that we
could that may not necessarily need to
be a fight at all
but i think they turn into them because
we handle we both have
we both handle angry um angerness
different so if i'm angry about
something then you've kind of talked
about like you use silence as a weapon
that's how i
do it is i'm just kind of turned quiet
and kind of shut myself off
whereas my wife will
sort of rage out and so both are wrong
uh and i definitely can do better now
i don't think both are wrong both are
just
are
maybe the situation with which they hurt
somebody else or when they are applied
to somebody else right i i'm a guy that
defaults to silence
until i switch flips that's what my wife
calls it
and
um man that's a good thing i don't say
stupid things i've never hit any you
know i mean i don't i'm not a violent
guy
um and so silence is a great default
network it's when i use silence
to get my way
that's when i'm i'm miss using or
sometimes exploding like will you please
just hear me or i'm so frustrated
um man i i totally get that it's when it
you do that at somebody and you hurt
somebody right so i don't i don't want
to lionize those things let me let me
back up a little bit here
um
you're 22 how old is she
she is about 21.
y'all are really young why'd you get
married so young
well you've been dating for a few uh
we've been dating for a little over two
years about almost three okay and we we
waited we wanted to get married right
after we graduated just because
living situation and we felt kind we
wanted to get but we wanted to figure
things out as we grew up together um
instead of trying to do it separately
and then coming back you know coming
together after a while doing that cool
so let me tell you a story like so when
i first got married um i remember the
time my wife and i don't know if i've
mentioned this on the show or not i i
remember time my wife was
next to me in the bathroom brushing her
teeth
and
i remember she took her toothbrush and
then she put toothpaste on the
toothbrush and because she's a serial
killer she shoved it directly into her
mouth and just started brushing her
teeth
and i remember looking at her and i said
you're doing that wrong
to it she's wise and she was like i
don't know this is a thing that you can
do wrong
enlighten me obi-wan and i said well the
way you're supposed to do it is you're
supposed to put toothpaste on the tooth
brush and then put it under the water
first and then put it in your mouth
weirdo
and someone who doesn't hate babies
and so
we both
walked into our marriage with just a
picture here's how you brush teeth right
both of you guys are dealing with
i thought my life was going to continue
as is i was just going to have my
husband or wife move into my my life
and so what you're here what you're
experiencing a super normal please don't
overreact to it okay you probably feel
trapped you probably feel buried up to
your neck right like what have i done
have you had those thoughts
oh yeah i wish you would just come in
and say we shouldn't have done this and
she would just leave like i wish i could
like there's just this
i get it and then if you're like most
not most
like many
um you have thoughts and then you get
really upset that you had those thoughts
like you're some kind of bad guy right
you're not okay
what you have is two people trying to
live
lives in their own lane and drag the
other person over into their lane
because this is the way life is going to
be
and what you haven't done yet and this
is what getting married at 28 29 or 30
will give you
is some tools to say
we are no long are the lives we led are
over
they do not exist anymore
we now have to in real time we have to
change the oil on this car while it's
driving we got to decide to build
something new together and that's a
totally different proposition
and so the picture you had up about what
what committed love is going to look
like in her picture does neither of
those matter
now what matters is here's a paintbrush
here's a paintbrush here's some
paintless paint something new together
let's figure something else out
and that starts with a conversation that
if you can get this down at 22 you will
you'll have the greatest marriage of
anybody i've ever met
and that is a cyclical
recursive like back and forth all the
time
every two months every three months
every quarter
we're gonna have a conversation where we
write it down what are your needs in
this season
we're both trying something new
how can i
best meet your needs even if it's going
to make me uncomfortable and i know it's
not very popular right now because it's
supposed to be like no it doesn't make
you uncomfortable you go do you bro
that's all stupid no relationships last
with that sort of infantile mentality
what you need is to say hey what can i
do
tell me
here's what i need i need physical touch
i need
sexual intimacy i need you to pick up
your underwear i need you to help make
the bed
and then here's what you can control on
that you
so when somebody calls and says hey how
do i fix my marriage how to
strengthen yourself
decide i'm gonna be the best freaking
husband who's ever lived
by meeting needs and by the way she's
gotta participate too this becomes a
very one-sided trip if she's like forget
you dude i'm not i'm not helping meet
your needs you weirdo
um
but you have to say these things out
loud and these are best done like not in
a fight
the little picky fights you're talking
about those are proxy wars that's the
that's you have no margin you have no
emotional margin you probably aren't
sleeping that well your diet's probably
all gone to hell you're just
everything's a mess right now you've
been married three months
and then the little there's just no
margin to absorb the
the where's the cup i thought you put it
over there and now
now we're in this fight for no reason
right
so it's
it's you've heard me say this so many
times i wish i could come up with
something new i was thinking about this
morning in the gym like i need to come
up with some new material
but really what you all need to do is go
decide like hey
i want to take you out we're three
months in
and
we've hit some bumps and some rocks and
some like just some normal growing pains
let's make something awesome and let's
decide what that's going to look like
and then we're going to practice it as
we move forward
and by the way one thing i want to give
you brandon
every time you get
start to get mad or frustrated or sad
or loud or angry
stop
say nothing okay
will you do that
absolutely yeah absolutely i'd love to
hear you learn at age 22 to say
i'm gonna need a minute
i'll be right back
you are you're fine i'm
i have
my insides have set on fire and i need a
minute
and um let me go for a walk real quick
let me go do 40 push-ups outside let me
go write something down and then i'll be
back
give me an hour give me 45 minutes or
whatever and if you can start that right
now creating a gap between your feeling
and then what you say or what you do or
getting angry
um
you're gonna have a lot of peace in your
home especially if your wife
joins along with you are these things
possible if you if you took her out and
said hey can we just like all right
three months in
i'm trying to force you to live in my
world and i feel like i'm getting
dragged into your world and what we need
to do is create our world what would
that even look like
could you start there
yeah would she be in on that
yeah she she'd be in she's
she's awesome love her to death
um
i'd say that something else that kind of
happens to
uh and she knows this too and um
and so i would say that when we get in a
fight it could be something really small
um
when she gets really upset and i i
you know have done this before and i try
my best not to do it and i don't think
i've done it when we've been married
but she'll lash out and she'll say some
like super hateful things and she'll
always apologize after she says them
give me an example
um
so when
uh she'll get upset about something or
will get upset and then one of the
things that she does is if it escalates
she'll say something like i hate you i
hate you or we should have never gotten
married and she she so sh so a little
bit after that you know i tell her that
really really makes me mad and you told
me last time you weren't going to say
that again
but at the same time i feel like i
really can't i i know that she needs to
take responsibility for actions as i do
too but she grew up in a home where it
was everybody said that
um everybody said that they hated each
other parents
didn't show their love to her and it was
it's sad so i'm trying to keep my
my head up when that stuff happens but
it just makes me really upset sure i
divorce is never on the table sure and
so okay let me hop in here here here's
what is your path forward okay
number one she cannot make you mad
that's a choice you make
okay okay
um and here's why that's important
it's very important outside of the heat
of battle outside of the heat of a
moment
um
you know what i'ma take back what i said
my wife can make me mad i've given her
permission to do that um so i'm gonna
take that back
you get to choose your response
very few people my boss can't make me
mad but i just don't give people that i
don't give them that i've worked for a
decade to decouple myself from other
people but i give my wife permission to
make me mad um i love her i
she gets permission to speak in my life
i have the choice on how i respond to
that how i act
here's
an important thing you all need in your
marriage
is really firm boundaries so you respond
when she says i hate you
your response or i wish we never got
married
you're responsive that really makes me
mad you've just poured gasoline on a
fire
right
good point in a non-fight
when you're out to breakfast you're out
to lunch and you're figuring out like
all right how are we going to build this
thing
you each get to make rules
and one of the rules for you one of your
boundaries is
if you say that you hate me
you are telling me that you want to end
the conversation and you want me to walk
away because that's what i'm choosing to
do
i will choose to leave the conversation
a hundred percent of the time you tell
me you hate me
every time
and so she's not um she will learn in
short order
that her husband has very strong
boundaries and then he will opt out
quietly with respect and i'm gonna walk
away
and by the way i don't care about her
childhood when it comes to that kind of
crap that is infantile acting like a
child she's got to stop that
okay it's destructive and again i wish
she'd gotten a better model when she was
a kid she didn't
and so she's got to stop
and that's got to be
you know she's going to practice
stopping that's all she knows she's 21.
um she's got a lot of maturity that
she's got to undergo in the next five 10
15 20 years or in my case 30 40 50 years
um
that's a no go absolutely no go but that
starts with you saying i will not accept
you telling me that you hate me i will
choose to lead that conversation you see
what i'm saying your response any
response after that is i'm choosing to
punch back and why right it's it's when
she crosses over there
you're fighting a generational fight
right she's fighting her parents she's
fighting their parents this has nothing
to do with you step out
right right
and at some point if she wants to solve
the actual challenge that's before you
if she wants to get closer to you become
more intimate with you
um she will know i'm not gonna throw
that grenade because that grenade is her
choosing i don't want you in my in my
space anymore
and um that's her choosing to be a child
a hurtful child
uh just aside listeners don't say you
hate people don't say you hate your
spouse or your kids don't say you want a
divorce
don't say we never should take that crap
off the table you're here you've done it
you did it okay
it's about what are we gonna do next
brandon
i've said this a thousand times i'll say
it a million times more until they
cancel the show which who knows i feel
like i'm always one go away
you can't live your life and drag her
into yours and she can't live her life
and drag you into hers you'll have to
decide that the lives y'all were living
are over they're over
who are we going to be together
we can both still have our dreams we can
both still have our goals and our lives
but they are now one they are not
together and we're going to build
something together moving forward and
you each get to state along that journey
what your needs are by the way your
needs will change and you both get to
state what the boundaries are you can't
talk to me like that i don't like to
touch in these situations
fill in the blank every couple makes
their own rules as they go
but you gotta state them out loud
you can do this brandon call me back in
about six months let me know how things
are going i'm excited for you guys